they're trying to sexualize children so  they're doing it with music to be clear  of nothing against trans people do what  you want but don't impinge sexuality on  children like children don't need to be  having drag queen Story Hour they don't  need to be going to Gay Pride events  where you have men in nothing but like  underwear whipping each other's bums you  do not need children there and the push  to have children there and the fact that  you know me saying what I'm saying  supposedly makes me a fascist and some  evil person obviously it doesn't but the  fact that I said and they they'll cancel  me for that is fascinating that's part  of a bigger thing to sexualize children